For many, becoming an actor is the ultimate dream
job. But most of these performers
had their sights set elsewhere.
"School of Rock" was a film that helped prove
Jack Black was more than just a gimmick. He
had appeared in movies before and found plenty
of success with his musical group Tenacious D,
but this was the flick that helped transform
him into a household name. What truly makes
him shine in "School of Rock" is the way he
works with his reluctant bandmates. And of
that group of students, there are few kids as
memorable as Lawrence, the keyboard maestro.
Played by Robert Tsai, Lawrence is one of
the most skilled performers in the band,
but his insecurities nearly
derail his opportunities.
"I don't think I should be in the band."
"Why not?"
"I'm not cool enough."
According to "School of Rock"
director Richard Linklater,
he drew on a real interaction with Robert
Tsai for Lawrence's emotional scene. Tsai
apparently tried to quit the film, telling
Linklater that he thought he was unfit for
the role. The director convinced him to stay
and reworked that conversation into a scene
where Lawrence expresses concern that
he's not cool enough to be in the band.
Tsai never acted again after "School of Rock," but
he continues to perform as a classical pianist.
For a bit of childhood wonder, look no further
than "Willy Wonka & the Chocolate Factory."
The 1971 movie is remembered for many things,
including Gene Wilder's iconic purple-suited
chocolatier, a number of deceptive traps, some
very ominous songs, and the blue-eyed hero of it
all — Charlie Bucket. Played by Peter Ostrum,
Charlie proves his selflessness to Wonka and
wins the day, sparking hope for his destitute
family when he is awarded Wonka's factory.
Ostrum told the Journal of the American Veterinary
Medical Association that after playing the role of
Charlie, he was offered a three-film deal by
the studio if he signed with them. However,
he declined in order to keep his options
open and give himself more freedom.
Though he did audition for a few more roles as
he got older, Ostrum was drawn to the world of
veterinary medicine. He eventually moved to New
York and claims he'd distanced himself from the
movie, rarely telling people about that part of
his life. But as he's grown older, he's embraced
that aspect of his history, especially the
mentoring relationship he had with Wilder.
Steven Spielberg's "Hook" is fondly remembered
for its incredible cast and fun reimagining of
the classic "Peter Pan" story. Who can forget
Dustin Hoffman's scenery-chewing Captain Hook
performance or Robin Williams' Peter Pan and his
playful banter with Julia Roberts' Tinker Bell?
The boo box? Run home Jack? Ru-fi-ohhh? We're
talking about a stone-cold classic right here.
"Looky looky, I got hooky"
Often lost in the shuffle is Peter's daughter,
Maggie. Played by then-seven-year-old Amber Scott,
Maggie has scene-stealing moments throughout
the film. But despite her terrific performance,
Scott's only other acting
credit is as a voice actor
on the historical documentary
series "American Experience."
Scott seemingly went on to a normal life as
she grew older, attending Trinity College and
getting her degree. She eventually updated her
headshot on IMDb and received a producer credit
for the short film "Cannonball." Maybe she's
still gearing up for a return to Hollywood,
but we haven't heard anything
in a few years from her camp.
There are only a handful of films that
commonly get mentioned in debates over
the best sci-fi movies of all time, but "Aliens"
is generally on the shortlist. Released in 1986,
it leans hard into its high-octane
action to tell an entirely different
story than its predecessor — one that
still holds up as a classic today.
"Aliens" is largely successful because of the
very relatable relationship between Ripley and
Newt — the scared little girl she protects from
the xenomorph menace. Played by Carrie Henn,
Newt gives the audience a surrogate
character who is just as terrified in
the face of an interstellar monster as we would
be, fighting to stay alive against all the odds.
Despite her strong performance, the timing just
didn't work out for Henn. After "Aliens" was
released, her family had already moved from
London to the United States. She told Wired
that she had grown more interested in becoming an
educator than an actor, leading her to a career as
an elementary teacher. Even so, Henn embraces her
legendary role; you can catch her at conventions,
and she is happy to sign autographs for
her students when they realize who she is.
The American road movie's poster child is "Easy
Rider," but there’s a number of films that fit
the category. One that often flies under the
radar is "Two-Lane Blacktop" — a minimalistic
film about a duo of road racers who flit across
the country in their Chevy 150. Singer-songwriter
James Taylor and Beach Boys drummer Dennis
Wilson play the lead roles. And while Taylor
has since done sporadic acting in his career,
Wilson only made this one appearance on film.
Wilson may have been primed for a successful
career as both a musician and an actor,
but one unlucky encounter seemed to derail
his life. The Beach Boys drummer had a habit
of picking up hitchhikers, and one day he
brought two young women back to his home.
After leaving for a recording session,
he came back to his house to discover the
women had invited even more people over.
One of them was a young Charles Manson.
As Wilson's life was slowly eroded by
Manson and his cult, he turned to heavy
substance abuse. He died at the age of 39,
drowning after diving into Marina Del Rey.
Though not as impactful as "The Omen," the
sequel is vastly superior to the third and
fourth entries in the franchise. And we
don't even bother with the 2006 remake.
In "Damien: Omen II," everyone's favorite
antichrist is a preteen living with his
uncle in Chicago and attending a military
academy. The only semblance of a true
friend he has is his cousin Mark, played
by Lucas Donat. When Mark learns Damien's
true nature and confronts him, Damien gives
him the chance to join him. Mark refuses,
and Damien kills his cousin in
order to protect his secret.
After leaving the acting profession,
Donat became a prolific advertising
executive for Tiny Rebellion — a firm
that won the 2014 Small Agency Award
from AdAge. Donat has been praised for
his disruptive approach and for helping
to spearhead the marketing campaigns for
companies like LegalZoom and eHarmony.